essayez de faire l'effort de prendre
l'escalier plutôt classe qu'elle a tort
de prendre les escaliers plutôt que
l'ascenseur si vous n'êtes pas en train
de monter en haut de la tour
montparnasse
voilà essayer de réfléchir à la façon
que vous pouvez avoir dans la journée
pour compenser la sédentarité que vous
vivez parce qu on est dans une société
qui est sédentaire
moi aussi je passe mon temps devant
l'ordinateur moi aussi je passe mon
temps assis sur mon scooter pour aller
me balader ou pour aller travailler
ils font que je compense toute la
journée je me dis tiens je restais
assise plus de tendeurs et ben je vais
compenser en essayant de faire une
activité d'être debout de marché de
descendre une station de métro par
exemple avant la station à laquelle je
descends d'habitude le problème c'est
qu'il faut en prendre conscience
on s'assoit en est sédentaire c'est
comme ça la société comme ça il faut
qu'on compense à un moment donné un rein
journée
[Musique]
nemat pas nécessaire et indispensable de
s'inscrire dans une salle de gym et de
dépenser de l'argent quand on en a pas
pour faire du sport et l'activité
physique s'est fait de bouger de marché
un peu plus vite dans la journée pendant
30 minutes chez les adultes une heure
chez chez les enfants il s'agit pas
d'aller faire un footing ou de
s'inscrire pour le marathon on peut
faire du sport avec ou de l'activité vie
avec n'importe quoi avec un petit ballon
essayé de descendre une station de métro
où une station de bus ou tramway avant
celle à laquelle on descend d'habitude
ne serait ce que pour accélérer pour
augmenter le l'est pas ou celles qui ont
dit qu'il faut faire entre 6000 et 10
mille pas par jour tout ça ça coûte rien
vous les avez à disposition
[Musique]
l'idée quand vous êtes adolescents mais
je sais que à travers brutaux on
s'adresse et aux ados et aux jeunes aux
jeunes adultes c'est que vous trouviez
quelque chose qui vous fait qui fait
quoi qui vous fait plaisir
si je vous dis voilà prenez vos
chaussures est allé faire un footing et
que ça vous plaît pas vous allez arrêter
au bout de deux semaines c'est pas le
but le but c'est que vous trouviez une
activité qui soit accompagné d'un
certain plaisir qu'ils soient ludiques
que ce soit une activité sol ou une
activité en groupe c'est toujours plus
sympa quand on partage ces moments avec
avec des potes
dites vous qu il ya d agréer parfois un
peu partout dans les villes et y en aura
de plus en plus on va en installer de
plus en plus en vue de paris 2024 la
situation de la france sur le plan de
l'activité physique et sportive des
enfants est absolument catastrophique je
crois qu'on se place il ya une étude
récente
119e 119e sur 145 ou 146 pays imaginez
quand même ça veut dire que
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
préconise que des enfants pratiquent une
activité physique de d'une heure par
jour au moins cinq jours par semaine
on n'en est pas là il ya 90 % des
enfants qui ne le font pas c'est à dire
qu'il ya 80% des garçons et plus de 90 %
des filles qui ne font pas cette heure
d'activité physique quotidienne et c'est
catastrophique c'est catastrophique
pourquoi tout simplement parce que des
enfants qui bouge pas front des adultes
qui bougeront pas que
lee des maladies cardiovasculaires du
diabète de tout un tas de choses dont on
peut reparler
ça commence à se faire chez les enfants
parce qu'ils sont tous en en surcharge
pondérale enfin tous y en a beaucoup il
ya 20% des enfants qui sont en surpoids
il y en a qui sont obèses et 5 % des
enfants qui sont obèses tous ces enfants
là il ne bouge pas et vous savez
pourquoi parce qu'ils sont souvent
devant leur écran aussi dans la dans la
journée donc la situation est
catastrophique en france alors on peut
voir ça d'un côté très négatif en se
disant c'est une catastrophe et ben
voilà on sait pas quoi faire mais nous
notamment ils parient 2024 on va essayer
de faire bouger des choses de profiter
de cette caisse de résonance incroyable
que constituent les jeux olympiques pour
justement changer les choses et essayer
de positiver